foreign
[Music]
but it's also supposed to seem genuine
to the public right so which chuckle
thought the best way to represent
translucent as a man of the people was
by showing him on a swing yes it's
hilarious visual for us but it's [__]
ridiculous as part of this propaganda I
was trying to go for something a bit
more personable down to earth not this
down to earth why is Courtney having a
pop at this editor as if the creative
Direction was all his fault look editors
can perform Feats of magic but surely he
didn't choose the content I refuse to
believe that he is the creative director
and editor in a company that has a
marvel-esque Cinematic Universe if your
brief wasn't clear enough that's on you
Courtney we here are not [__] Heidi
and Spencer even in 2019 Heidi and
Spencer references were dated enough to
earn you a sin and having to hear the
reference in 2023 means you're getting
five has a Heavenly Body lost her luster
I suppose a few seconds of news position
is better than two minutes of previously
ons but this is still sure we saw
literally at the end of last episode
stop acting like we aren't binging this
entire show in one afternoon after
starlight's shocking appearance at the
believe Expo social media is still
buzzing Gotta Love slash sin news
stations that are perfectly synchronized
to continue each other's sentences for
the convenience of expositional Channel
hopping who's that dude that stuck his
in her face
nope okay okay those weren't our bleeps
those were the news stations bleeps
which means one of two things is
happening here this is either a live
interview or someone's predictively
bleeping the swears and blurring her
lips or this is a recorded interview
which the anchor should not be shocked
by drinking beer by the pitcher yes I
know what happens but we really need to
stop supporting the idea that this is a
good way to consume your carbonated
yeast I mean how easy do you have to be
to prefer room temperature flat beer
instead of making the short walk to the
bar between pints Five Flags down into a
pet store where he hides behind this
jumbo bag of Kibbles and bits for four
hours the scariest part of this story is
that there's a pet store that just let a
kid hide behind a bag of dog food for
four hours and doesn't check on him to
see if he needs any help I've been
worried [__] backhanded sentiments
Olivia life
no I think what Robin would want is to
not have been jellowed at high speed for
no good reason can we stop speaking for
the dead as if this is supposed to make
grieving people feel better my
grandfather built this place with his
bare hands that's me in the middle
homelander's Homestead is all set up to
look like he had a typical American
Childhood but isn't this all easily
disprovable these weren't really his
parents and I bet his grandfather had
nothing to do with building this house
so isn't putting this picture in fairy
tale out there risky I mean butcher and
Friends manager didn't cover a lot more
with far less Cubs fans welcome to my
bedroom hasn't changed a bit great
observation why hasn't it changed at all
homelander implies that his parents died
when he was pretty young so why is this
house been kept as if it were some sort
of shrine to his childhood so no hero
was born none
they're all just kids just with the blue
I can't even begin to describe what it
would take to support a conspiracy of
this size putting aside the people
involved in the secret creation and
distribution of compound V we'll find
out that some parents even volunteered
their children to be injected and after
nearly 50 years no one has come forward
or leaked any of this to the Press sure
it's not impossible but if Butcher and
this lot have managed to uncover the
whole damn thing in a matter of months
I'd imagine someone else would have
managed to All the President's Men
themselves to the truth as well
the whole Corridor can hear this
Stillwell's office should be the most
soundproof room in the whole [__]
building considering what goes on in
there and I think we may need to
reconsider your position in the seven
and I think that firing an employee
after she reported sexual assault on
live TV might tank your stock price I
love Annie claiming her power in this
scene I just wish it didn't come at the
expense of making Stillwell looked naive
sure she might see Annie as new and
malleable at this point but she must see
how firing her would look pretty hideous
whichever way they choose to dress it up
and why bother to save the Deep why is
her preference to get Annie off the
books instead of dealing with a
persistent boner burden that is the Deep
you really stood for something
yeah
pretty sure that was just written by the
marketing guys elevators that know
exactly when to arrive to give Maximum
Impact to your big Zinger this would
have been really awkward if they had
another 10 floors to go listen I got one
word for you it's a Surefire way to
solve this puzzle is it gonna be a soup
that just so happens to have a power
that would be extremely helpful in this
situation and is also vulnerable enough
to be taken advantage of by a bunch of
non-soups but for some reason hasn't
been mentioned until now this yeah that
sounds right I've seen you eat ice cream
oh my gosh
where's this going well Frenchy will
create a terrible and not very
convincing chunky monkey metaphor to get
mother's milk to go along with his
terrible plan of involving another soup
so in other words this works also no one
actually eats chunky monkey it's just a
catchy name that's fun to say we need to
expose the myth people hashtag chunky
monkey is a lie no one wants to [__] the
writer hey wait hold up I mean that's
not true no that's fair she climaxed and
accidentally turned into ice as you can
imagine
um it snapped off which makes Seth
insanely lucky that he only lost his if
he was that close to Ice Princess when
she became negative 346 degrees the
entire outside of his body should have
been affected too or at the very least
he should have had a pair of Frozen Seth
stickles please do uh continue the Oscar
bites we don't make jokes or judgments
here well sad I mean how else can you
expect poor Seth to Let It Go let it go
we don't get a good look at it but I
think it's hilarious that translucent
has a bust that is likely well just the
stand I'm gonna need you to make a
public apology and you're going to be
taking a sabbatical from the seven she's
doing this [__] now in the corridor
still strikes me as the type of person
who likes to control things so I'd
expect this to happen in our office and
likely with homelander present just in
case an emergency deprying is required
it's only a matter of time before she or
let's be honest some of the other women
speak up again very damaging
conversations are being had in the
middle of the [__] Corridor now for
the record [__] the deep in everything
he is but I'm just stunned that it isn't
in Stillwell's best interest to be
choreographing this in private our new
movie Insurrection it's really exciting
a superhero movie with Seth Rogen in it
imagine someone thinking that was a good
idea glad that's never horneted I mean
happened
that was weird also thinking that using
the subtitle Insurrection for your movie
is ever a good idea but there's only one
person who can see inside their hearts
and read their minds so Mesmer is
apparently a child star that's been
neglected and tossed aside by Vaught but
why we'll get told it happened after
some insider trading but his power is
insane the ability to read people's
minds should make him one of the most
in-demand soups on the planet and he's
out here doing the convention circuit
who chooses the over Mesmer seeing does
not contain the crow Wicked prayer
poster scene also never confirms that
Billy Zane is reprising his role as the
Phantom in the boys of verse do it you
cowards do it what number am I thinking
of
67. it's like Mesmer has a sixth sense
or something I guess it could also be an
artificial intelligence and it's really
not for not for the power like that to
yourself he really should pay it forward
secondhand lines once you want Teenage
kicks with a train considering Mesmer
hates Vaught in soups I don't know why
I'd be wearing this other than to
advertise to us that he has a link to a
train who the [__] are you why don't you
take a peep and see it's really odd
seeing the kid from Sixth Sense playing
a character that has superpowers very
similar to Bruce Willis's character in
Unbreakable or a few rapidly aging Beach
bumsy sundowning elderly woman and an
alien killing glass of water from the
boys being part of the shyamalaniverse
am I sitting this show for not becoming
part of the shyamalaniverse yes yes I am
do the writers think it's funny to make
me say shyamalaniverse yes yes they do
how do you know about Cleo well I work
for child services
I love transitions like this have they
just been walking in silence all this
time this cup makes it seem like they
left the convention walked across this
field and are only now picking up this
conversation again
you have a DVD player being reminded how
much owning physical media is becoming a
thing of the past my wife Becca used to
Humble Spice Girls I'll tell you what I
want what I really really want I really
really really want a zigga skip ah just
remember do your friends using the we're
your real friends tactic to get a person
who is at best A co-worker on your side
might as well go ahead and talk about
how everyone in the office is just one
big happy family
off
that is gonna kill somebody when it
lands in Boston breaking the ice by
referencing a future manslaughter so
what if I took you
to a house you'd never seen before full
of photos of parents you never met toys
you never played with
Hardy Boy books that you never read
acting like if there are Hardy Boys
books in front of you you're not just
going to quit what you're doing and read
all of them ASAP Frank and Joe deserves
better homelander also my goodness is
there anything other than emotions left
in this episode I said skip I'm really
sorry about the blanket it never should
have been there and Randy set deck has
already been terminated cool but how did
Randy said deck ever get a hold of
homelander's actual childhood blanket
why would that even be a thing that
still exists at Vaught they're hardly
the sentimental type so wouldn't it have
either been discarded and never seen
again or locked away so securely that
random Randy set deck would never have
accidentally been able to get a hold of
it let's just go walk it off she broke
my [__] wrist Mesmer would be
mesmerizing at TV sins
to my find your [__] Friends app
okay this explains why butcher is able
to pop in at extremely convenient times
but those apps require the other
person's phone permission too and as
resourceful as butcher is can you
imagine any of these guys being dumb
enough to leave their phones unattended
and unlocked near him I mean other than
Huey of course well there we go kill him
saying you've got to kill someone loud
enough for the person you're talking
about killing to hear Frenchie you're
dating the terrorist
true Frenchie expects to get an answer
to this question from a woman who's been
almost 100 silent since he met her in a
show no indication that she speaks or
understands English also friendship will
be deeply hurt by this Revelation but
I'm shocked by his lack of perspective
by many definitions he and the rest of
the boys are the terrorists in this
situation Vaude is the accepted power
and they're working against them in a
pretty illegal fashion get off your high
horse Frenchie and wait for some context
the scene with baby homelander that this
blanket leads to is one of the best
parts of the episode but if you think
I'm not sending the conveniently placed
baby blanket being on top of this pile
then welcome to the channel you must be
new here don't forget Thursday we have a
mime coming in to reenact the entirety
of Schindler's List it's gonna be
special never got the point of these to
me I always look like granddad's box
flopping in the wind you would think
that how many
butcher's Granddad have and why did
butcher ever have occasion to see them
would at least crack the top 10 weirdest
questions the show has made me ask but
you would be wrong I can give you
everything you want on this list
except
except homelander then what's the
[__] point of the investigation if
the FBI are terrified of homelander why
are they even bothering to go after
Vaught homelander is Vaught so what
makes her think that going after them is
any less dangerous is if you watched
that episode of Downton Abbey then I'm
gonna be one behind and we're not gonna
be able to binge watch together using a
Downton Abbey reference to show the
masculine man has a hard cliche also
making your better halfway till it's
convenient for you to watch the next
episode of Downton Abbey Carson and
Bates are going to get in a fight and
strongly harumpet each other this week
what kind of monster are you Mother's
Milk also also binge watching Tina um
it's raspberry why is he using his soup
name to the CPS lady he has an actual
name for official right there's this
beach in the Bahamas that's just are we
talking about this I understand the
confusion Huey because there is zero
about the interactions you've had with
Starlight over the past five episodes
and change that has led me to believe
she would not only be willing to move to
a tropical island with you but would
also be the one to suggest it I would go
get us a picture
Billy you like let me guess Guinness who
drinks Guinness from a pitcher
waiting 57 minutes and 54 seconds to
finally Billy Joel us
rubbish we don't want to be happy we
want to be famous yeah that's me all
right and the guy standing next to me is
President Gerald Ford sorry I don't you
don't get it do you I don't want to be
your stupid quarterback
I would like you to take this in the
constructive spirit that it is intended
I'm gonna rip the eyes out of your head
are my teeth not white enough or like
the Great Falls is the Bedrock of my
life
eroding beneath me
nope
go again you gotta be
kidding you have something you'd like to
share the Iceman Cometh don't call me
stupid all right to call you it would be
an insult to
assault just like a girl